[Music]
in the early 2000s a new phrase entered
the chinese vernacular renzo may knew
it means artificial beauty and it laid
the foundation for what's become a
cultural phenomenon in china cosmetic
treatments
the miss plastic surgery pageant in 2004
marked the country's growing acceptance
towards going under the knife
all part of a cosmetic surgery boom
fueled by the country's burgeoning
middle class who have more disposable
income than any generation before them
if you look historically sociologically
and philosophically beauty has always
been a commodity for centuries you go
back to the ancient egyptians or the
ancient chinese they always placed a
very high regard on people who are
beautiful what's changed nowadays is
that you can buy a bit of that beauty
but as they say beauty is in the eye of
the beholder in china however beauty is
increasingly becoming in the hands of
plastic surgeons the country's facial
and body enhancement industry
is booming
the market in china is now worth over 30
billion dollars making up 17 of the
global industry
innovations in non-surgical and surgical
procedures have brought prices down to a
cost accessible to everyone
with the advent of dissolvable fillers
botox
we have realized that we can achieve
some form of beauty without actually
having to undergo the knife
the arrival of dedicated cosmetic apps
have made booking surgery as simple as
ordering a takeout
but breakout growth has left regulators
playing catcher
and as the chinese government looks to
crack down on the cosmetic surgery
industry the days of paying for
perfection might be numbered
[Music]
[Applause]
so i've been in china operating working
teaching
and observing the changing trends for
the last 17 years and i will say that
people have gotten a lot more bold in
what they want to see for themselves
dr waffles wu who currently operates out
of singapore has been a plastic surgeon
for over 30 years
in 2006 he was appointed the honorary
head of plastic surgery at a hospital in
hangzhou where he trained surgeons
over the years he's seen china's
industry grow not only in size but also
ambition
20 years ago
it would have been the usual kind of
double eyelid or maybe a little bit of a
higher nasal bridge and that would be it
they'd be happy with that
but
with a lot of products and a lot of new
techniques being available to the
chinese they've gone into it full force
and so now they're into contouring the
face
shaving the cheekbones shaving the jaw
bones doing their nose their eyes their
breasts
and fixing their skin china's medical
aesthetics industry which includes
surgery injections and skin treatments
has been growing at an unmatched rate
its cosmetic surgery market which was
virtually non-existent a few decades ago
is now the second largest in the world
after the us
with an annual expansion that's more
than three times faster than anywhere
else it's poised to become the biggest
this year
in 2020 sales revenues were an estimated
51 billion dollars
like many industries in china technology
and innovation over the last two decades
have played a central role
in early 2000s majority of the marketing
was done offline just traditional
advertising on the streets but then it
sort of gradually evolved on if i do so
so more sort of on the internet browser
searches space
but then in the recent past few years
we've seen lots of vertical integrated
mobile phone apps being advanced in the
market
looks fancy
be kind
lengths of my two eyes are different it
says
mei which means more beautiful in
chinese and so young are just two of the
many social networking platforms in
china dedicated to cosmetic surgery i
can't read this but it's obviously
saying it's perfect
from connecting prospective patients to
recommending nearby surgeons and even
offering micro loans to pay for the
treatments these apps are a one-stop
shop for all things beauty
cute face
great
within minutes of logging on a user can
book and pay for pretty much any
treatment on the market and if you can't
decide what you want done it can help
with that too
aloof girl's face who needs filler
so i think this is now a lot more first
hand and interactive consumers can now
quite easily get their hands on
to read understand some of the treatment
they want to receive
[Music]
for many consumers the apps offer more
transparency around procedures than
previous forms of advertising
and the sheer volume of information
available has made the decision to go
under the knife much easier
so young has already been downloaded
more than 400 million times in china
since its launch in 2014
because of the internet and the way they
advertise of course that knowledge
becomes instantly available to anybody
looking for plastic surgery so it has
really grown
but public awareness around unhealthy
beauty standards are growing
in august china's market regulator
drafted guidelines to reform advertising
practices saying that they were
prompting societal anxiety over people's
looks
they try to appeal to their potential
consumers and with the message that you
know your body is something that you can
improve so meaning that even your
identity is not pinned down so then
that's one of the strategy and then it
what we call in in academia
interpolation so meaning that you know
you position the consumer in in a place
where uh they feel that you know they
are summoned to conceal this product
then they also have diverse procedures
so they made it so uh at different price
range why don't you have lots of money
and then you can have something um you
know more expensive but if you even have
you know not so much money but you can
still save money and to have a simple
procedure
cost is always a factor when it comes to
cosmetic surgery because that's
disposable income right
millennials in china many of whom have
grown up as part of the one child policy
have more disposable income than ever
before
the country will more than double the
number of millionaires in the next five
years and boost the size of its middle
class by almost half
cosmetic surgery is a conspicuous
consumption
so in a sense it was almost like a
luxury item right and when people have
more money they have more disposable
income so they feel that it's all right
to um you know use that money as a kind
of investing um to to show that they can
consume something that was not available
to the previous generation
but even for those with a little less
cash to spend there are options
traditional surgery to give you a nasal
bridge with a piece of silicone or a
piece of gore-tex
would cost upwards of ten thousand
dollars
but with a syringe of filler
which you can just inject in the clinic
you can get a semblance of that
improved projection and contouring of
the nose and that costs about one-tenth
if not less
than the surgery itself so for somebody
who's a little tight on budget they
would tend
to do the non-surgical procedures which
are infinitely cheaper than the surgical
procedures and with fewer complications
so that has been a burgeoning
market and it's always what we call the
entry point for these young people who
wish to dabble in plastic surgery as
they would dabble with new makeup
the average age for those going under
the knife in china is 24 years old with
over 80 percent being female and the
number of under 20s opting for
treatments is increasing
one of the most popular procedures among
the younger clientele is double eyelid
surgery
i did a double eyelid surgery in july
2016 after the university entrance
examination
i did it mainly for two reasons the
first is
i don't like my single eyelid it's very
difficult to make
another reason is my mom she thinks my
eyes are too small so
surgery is very
necessary
eyelid surgery was one of the popular
procedures for one thing it was quite
affordable in comparison to a nose drop
so it might cost just a couple hundred
us dollars say about one thousand
chinese units
you know this one try policy i mean
parents are quite willing to help the
children to get started you know at a
very competitive society
i heard about numerous stories actually
about
parents paying for this kind of simple
surgery as a gift for graduation for
example
beyond just aesthetics some consumers
hope that changing their face may change
their fate in the country's highly
competitive job market
today you have to be beautiful to
succeed
the competition to find a job is so
fierce many believe being operated on
helps you stand out a new report is
drawing attention to widespread gender
discrimination in job ads for chinese
companies
in 2018 a human rights watch report
pointed to several job postings that
openly specified requirements in gender
and appearance
changing their aesthetic beauty they can
somehow enjoy some social advantages
several people tell me that they can
find a better job for example at the job
market or they feel that it's investment
um
in the sense that in the long term they
can get some kind of a return
it's not so much about whether or not
they like to have cosmetic surgery but
rather they feel that that's an
opportunity that they cannot miss out so
if they can actually invest a little bit
money and then undergo
a painful procedure but however there is
a reward at the end so they they will
try the best you know to do it if they
can afford it
like many parts of the world beauty
standards are being set and exacerbated
by the presence of influencer and
celebrity culture
they're constantly bombarding the
internet space with images of what
they think a beautiful face should be
and people therefore follow that and
feel that that's what we should look
like because everybody else is doing it
and all the influences that have a
certain kind of facial look so this does
rub off on the
younger people
and it's exactly the same in china as it
is in singapore or any other part of
asia
in a chinese culture that had a peer
pressure and emulation can you know
become a norm that people internalized
and then later on kind of spread around
you will see some of the internet
celebrities sometimes they might have a
doctor that's special in the field to
really sort of um
speak quite openly
and in-depth about some of the
treatments
but the same influences that helped
build the buzz have also fallen victim
to its darker side
during the industry's explosive growth
demand for surgery massively outgrew the
number of qualified practitioners able
to supply it
unlicensed clinics began performing
illegal surgeries which led to some
fatalities
about 40 000 medical accidents occur in
these unlicensed clinics every year an
average of about 110 per day
china had over 80 000 unlicensed
institutions in 2019 accounting for
about 84 of the market with uncertified
physicians making up 72 percent of all
practitioners
but change could be coming we will make
more notable and substantive progress
toward achieving well-rounded human
development and common prosperity for
all
president xi jinping's common prosperity
plan has seen entire sectors ordered to
change the way they do business
the government really is pushing through
some house cleaning when it comes to
china's economy they are talking about
enforcing laws and regulations on so
many corners of the economy at the
moment
industries that ballooned over recent
decades have faced particular scrutiny
leading analysts to question how long it
will be before the cosmetic sector gets
hit
since the start of july the market value
of the country's three biggest publicly
traded medical aesthetics companies has
fallen by a third
representing a collective loss of more
than 17 billion dollars as the industry
plays a waiting game
so i think naturally there will be some
reform in the market both in terms of
crackdowns on malpractice by that i mean
companies that do not have the business
license and the in the right
accreditation to operate or give surgery
in the market and i think second is also
regarding the reform on how authority
can better regulate um some of the
advertising of this institute
i can understand you know if there are
changes that can truncate you know or uh
cut tail you know part of the industry
or make it less profit driven so that
would probably be the trend because
industries like that at least in the
chinese case always serve the ideology
of the ruling government
but there are signs that the market
could survive under a more watchful life
from beijing
medical tourism could even become a
driver for the economy if the government
can ease widespread safety concerns
they've made these special medical
tourism zones where foreign companies
can go and set up much more easily
foreign doctors can go and get their
license much more easily as well
there are certain tax breaks that i
think are afforded to them and so a
number of american european companies
have moved into these areas to set up
shop so that they can open up
manufacturing plants and provide china
with a constant stream of these
essentially foreign-made products and i
think the chinese authorities have done
this because they realize that medical
tourism is a very big
item
and can bring in a lot of tourist
dollars
[Music]
plastic surgery is a very normal thing
in china many young people will change
something they not very sentient values
but i don't think
beauty is everything but confidence
maybe
can really take you some more
better opportunities but i think if you
are not beautiful but you are very
confident and talented the opportunity
is
also
there for you so i don't think it's just
the benefits of the beauty
you